est ce que vous êtes heureux est-ce que
vous avez passé une belle année mathieu
c'est très très content vraiment
s'éclater un jury moi j'aime bien j'ai
bien aimé soutenu la partie qui avait
pas avant qu'à la partie des bas de fin
ouais je me suis trouvée très brillant
j'ai adoré j'étais contente et heureuse
ouais ça va je suis content et vous vous
aimez vous êtes contents de nous de oui
chez moi je vais vous dire moi je suis
pragmatique ouais ça marche je suis
content ça marche pas je coupe les têtes
moi je me repose je ne mens pas je ne
mens pas public voilà maintenant mais je
suis très content appuyons on a une
ambiance de fou étiez content d'être
près de moi à très très beau temps est
revenu au caire au sérieux bien amusé
moi j'aime bien aussi particulièrement
quand ça casse un peu le conducteur pour
les matches qu'on a fait ou avant-hier
et crémont ça c'est vraiment les
émissions je m'amuse aussi des émissions
se frottent quoi
voyez vraiment les émissions ne me
suivantes bien bien amusé donc merci
beaucoup ma mère manon chanter peut dire
écoutez moi si je peut vous permettre de
gagner votre vie d'où sa visite ça me
fait évidemment plaisir non mais ça ne
valait pas un seigneur
ta gueule
valérie gilles et on me suis très très
heureuse moi je suis est apte à passer
une bonne année j'ai passé une très très
belle année j'adore cette nouvelle cette
formule qui mélange la formula k 800
mélange comme ça à la fois ce qui fait
l'adn c'est à dire votre folie la folie
des copains parce qu'ils sont tous sur
du full et est de plus en plus et ouais
vraiment vraiment et en même temps les
débats de société les débats de fond on
se frotte et on n'est pas d'accord mais
où après quand on sort on sera aussi
vous aimez vous frottez
beaucoup et et non j'étais très heureuse
et moi je suis bien avec mes camarades
je les aime non ainsi ouais ouais bah si
on les aimait c'est quoi votre meilleur
souvenir de la saison à tout cela
mathieu à moi en invité par exemple non
mais trouve le meilleur souvenir de
l'émission il n'a eu pas mal mais je ne
suis pas qu'avant tiennent avec réponse
et c'est vraiment une émission ou série
de a à z j'ai vraiment adoré pardon
c'est peut-être pas le alors bien vous
le direz vous inspire moins bon mon
meilleur souvenir c'est avec un invité
ah bon pour nous dire et dans un instant
benjamin ça va vous a très bien écouté
j'ai passé une excellente saison avec
vont comprendre
et nous formons un vrai duo et j'adore
me faire faire bousculer par vous et ça
me fait plaisir des amoureux et eko eko
n'ont pas trop mais les gens me
demandent toujours mais tu aime bien
quand tu s'il te touche à légitimer non
seulement j'aime bien mais ça fait
partie du show et j'adore ça sur ça mais
voilà donc une ride c'est comme ça que
ça fonctionne et j'ai franchement
j'adore merci ben oui j'ai adoré brandon
moi ça devrait vous remplacez le
vendredi je me suis épaté j'adorais
vraiment l'a confirmé comme je suis la
femme de trop ça ne
les mets donc quand je suis pas là j'ai
adoré la confiance que vous m'avez fait
le coin et c'est très touchant pour pour
moi massez vous le dire et je voulais
vous dire à quel point je vous aime
voilà
vous savez ça fait sept ans qu'on se
connaît oui ça fait donc cet encours est
tendu la main quand plus personne ne
l'attendait donc c'est plutôt pas mal et
me fait confiance et c'est très très
franchement on se régale avec benji je
dis toujours banier c'est le frère ou
c'est toujours absolue samaké dit
certains mac etc et alors elle a passé
une belle année celle ci j'ai passé de
bonnes années vous résumer la saison ce
serait apaisement cette fois ci un peu
parce que j'ai trouvé que l'émission
elle était fluide la cohésion du groupe
elle était fluide avec vous c'était
fluide aussi chez didier deschamps
j'adore la fluidité dans tous les sens
du terme ouais donc j'ai trouvé ça hyper
chouette cette année vraiment tout s'est
bien passé et on est tous eu fidh
bernard mon team merci qui dit merci
c'était sympa ce qu'elle a dit oui
oui ce qui vous reste que vous me
demandez je vous réponds c'est normal ce
que j'aime le plus dans cette émission
c'est la liberté que nous avons chacun
de nous exprimer ça tout le monde peut
s'exprimer dieu sait qu'on n'est pas
tous d'accord ensemble mais on est libre
de s'exprimer et ça c'est bien toi que
tu as gagné y en a je peux pas blairer
amitié géraldine j'aime tout le monde du
rallye de jeu l'as d'or le sait
le débat est intéressant et les
personnalités que vous avez reçus et
vous avez toujours une façon très
particulière de recevoir les invités il
s'assure nulle part ailleurs on voit ça
et j'apprécie beaucoup ça parce que
c'est en direct en plus c'est formidable
c'est que si tu en as we were la
fluidité l'éxil sexuelle bien finir en
au registre mais j'espère bien
gérer leur propre alors moi j'ai préparé
un poème est ce que je lis maintenant ou
plus tard
[Rires]
delphine c'est pourquoi mais en fait
parce qu'en fait le dernier jour c'est
un peu comme la kermesse étant donné qu
ici c'est comme une cour de récréation
oui et donc je réponds oui j'ai jamais
fait un poème avec des rimes jeu là pour
passer pour moi ouais avec 1 écoutez
bien les rimes mairie mais surtout
écoutez bien tout les rimes situer mais
là la merguez c'est que tu n'es pas à
l'aise je connais ça s'appelle fabien de
lettres au collège
non je crois pas un instant
bien
c'est mon pote fabien delahaye qui a dû
les cloches sonnent à delphine voir si
tu fais voilà c'est si tu tiennes
mauvaise bout il sait que tu as mal au
cou y
va me permettre je suis témoin les créé
à côté de moi on était en droit et celle
qu'il a écrit ce soit à l'asie alors
alors chers cyril ça démarre toujours
bien pour moi vous êtes un génie par
vous nous avons tellement appris au nom
de tous les chroniqueurs on vous
souhaite le meilleur c'est vraiment
utile
j'avoue j'avais dû trembler est ce que
tu en prends ça bien
vacances et qui france pour tout ce que
vous avez fait pour la france
société et actualité quel plaisir d'être
à vos côtés
c'est la vie c'est le
plaisir d'être à vos côtés
grâce à votre confiance nous parlerons
bientôt alliance grâce à vous des
couples se mettront à genoux oui le 30
juin pour se demander leurs mains alors
pour finir le poème je dirais tout
simplement bien on s'aime hasbro votre
émission
[Applaudissements]
c'est par une bande annonce
d'abord il n'ya pas une bande annonce
aussi j'ai adoré la saison je me suis
senti très à l'aise et surtout pour moi
le mot c'est pas fluidité c'est
confiance vous m'avez fait confiance
j'ai su reprendre ma place et confiance
aussi par rapport à cette émission du 30
juin sur voilà la balle 30 joueurs vous
regardera et on fera on fera une promo
merci sera invitée chez benjamin
castaldi comme pour la promo de
l'émission quand même ah oui ah oui oui
oui même ce serait oui mais je vous dis
oui je pense que oui
métro s'est pas produit mais ça reste
sympa c'est très abstrait béatrice la
nouvelle ça fait à peu près quatre mois
que je suis là vous avez été une
surprise dans ma vie vraiment je suis
assis moi même on m'avait dit que je
serais ici je l'aurais pas cru et vous
et tous d'ailleurs et toute l'équipe les
gens
c'est une émission incroyable unique et
franchement il y a que vous qui je pense
qu' être capable de faire ça est ce que
j'apprécie beaucoup c'est que vous
pousser les gens à d'or
[Applaudissements]
ces batteries aussi mais pas que vous
poussez les jouera à dépasser leurs
limites et vous nous poussez à lâcher
prise ce qui est la chose la plus
difficile au monde et voilà je vous
remercie et big n vraiment
merci à tous une expérience et la gala
après
c'est avec la longue à l'annoncer
perdant mais c'est ici qu'a c'était
chaud pour bien gilles verdez il est
fâché toujours ça mais ça va mieux ça va
beaucoup mieux franchement c'était une
année de rêve franchement moi j'ai adoré
j'ai adoré créer puis vous fait
pratiquement toutes les émissions oui
alors c'est comme d'habitude sauf en
septembre voulais me dégager
ben oui comme d'habitude ce sera pareil
à des procès ça fait dix ans que ça dure
donc va bien moi j'ai adoré travailler
avec certains de mes camarades
avec les équipes éditoriales que je
voulais le dire franchement elles sont
top massa elle bosse et nous y
voilà il les a tous mis à l'essai est
beau ce match je les connais pas mais
j'ai bien aimé vous les connaissez je
les connais bien sûr vu que fut bien
seul but amicalement ballon et donc j'ai
adoré cette saison et et merci de me
supporter tout au long de ces dix années
parce que je sais que je suis très
chiant non mais voilà vous êtes un
walkman fermeture merde pas et fait
cesser sinon merde pas excusé donc merci
à vous les mecs il va falloir qu'on est
un peu plus vite parce que j'ai vu il ya
plein de trucs à faire un qui va falloir
vous maniez le fion
gentil moi
j'ai très rapidement je suis super
heureuse ou me donner beaucoup de force
beaucoup d'amour je pensais pas démarrer
une carrière de gogo danseuse à mon âge
donc franchement c'est inespéré yeah
yeah et là je peux venir à la date
annoncée j'ai donné hier à quoi annoncer
à bahreïn hors caméra
de danse
ouais cereal téké cadence et
j'ai écrit un poème très très court
l'ipad 2 dans
ses traits quoi pour
les trois lignes nous allons nous
quitter pour quelques longues semaines
et rien que d'y penser ça me fait de la
peine nous avons partagé des fous rires
déçu c'est tu m'as chauffaient beaucoup
et moi je t'ai sus est situé le savait
dire tu es belle elle aura bon royan
roule mois donc une pelle
[Applaudissements]
jamais rassasiée avant chroniqueurs
n'ont alors gentiment
j'ai déjà dit j'ai déjà beaucoup donné
ou pas du tout cas
ce sera je crois que c'est le 17 août 17
août à l'accord payant chanceuse c'est
tout voilà voilà non non pas de règle
rah-e-sabz inquiétez pas on est en
contact
qui était pas on regarde on garde le
contact c'était pour la répu normes et
bien sûr et puis hier soir on a dansé
ensemble c'était chaud très des choses
c'était chaud est ce qu'on raconte
chaque soirée non
c'est bon j'ai chaud et daniel je peux
dire c'était chaud et b vraiment non moi
j'ai kiffé cette saison j'ai quitté j'ai
kiffé la partie orange vous quand on
commence tu fous le tu fout le bordel
non j'ai adoré les animations de ça j'ai
kiffé après ça devient bleu il ya les
deux des
débats de société j'adorais cette saison
2 vous cette saison était folle on a
parlé de tout et on a rigolé et une
division j'ai adoré diviser la date
l'heure et adoré francis lalanne moi
j'ai dû rigoler tout à l'heure il y aura
du rabibochage
mathieu avec fabrice di vizio et gilles
favard
[Rires]
m
ces classes le piège vous inquiétez pas
sympa sa dernière j'ai adoré et puis
mention spéciale pour succès de face à
baba qui arrivait de nulle part sur
cette saison dans une période électorale
les gens les gens ont adoré et j'ai
adoré cette émission qui a parlé aux
gens et qui a peut-être aidé les gens à
voter doit pas voter et à revenir à la
politique mention spéciale pour ce
qu'elle est et reste un petit peu
ça va bien pour moi je te comprends
maintenant qu'ils courent aimons comme
mathieu géraldine savary mois comme
chinula l'orage vous ai fait une petite
lettre dans ce port est en mairie cher
cyril cette année j'ai été heureuse
contrarier effaré choquée j'ai était
hilare peiné dégoûté émerveillé j'ai été
fatigué galvanisés j'ai été content j'ai
été pour géante j'ai été anti pro j'ai
été son filtre sans langue de bois j'ai
été forte puis fragiles puis re forte
j'étais comme moi j'ai été moi comme
jamais dans tpm paix c'est un sacré
ascenseur émotionnel donc merci pour ça
on finit le mission souvent en disant la
télé c'est que la télé ben moi pour moi
la télé c'est aussi un peu plus parfois
alors on est surpris cote
our anime c'est bien la région et au
tison et de on est sûr que c'est pas des
films qu'il a écrit
voilà mais pas le riz mais darwin c'est
adeline crs pedigree ces gens le sell
jean jacques goldman de l'ordre
s'étaient rangées limiers
de succès à
mon meilleur pour la fin on a mis cyril
mon coeur je vais te remercie pour cette
saison comme peut-être un jour au
serveur d'un restaurant chinois terme et
qu'on dort jamais
et permettez moi de vous sucer quand une
petite lettre que je vous ai écrites
allez-y cheikh ba ba je ne sais pas si
je dois te tutoyer comme l'ami que tu es
où te vous voyez pour faire honneur à
son rang de demi-dieu du paddle
quoi qu'il en soit l'idée de passer deux
mois loin de toi me détruis terrible son
rire semblable à du mozart qu'on allure
d'athlètes them'all est bien ferme des
petites fesses en pain d'épicé
sache que si cet été tu me cherches j'ai
loué la maison à côté de la tienne dans
le sud comme d'habitude et si tu veux
jouer avec des balles je serais tout de
suite là mais je ne parle pas de paddle
je t'aime
[Applaudissements]
ces rayons vous demande de l'embrasser
vous l'embrassez et daniel alors là
c'est le rouler une pelle ça va
ouais s'est frotté à moi comme un tampon
jacques cyr